[Musique]
14 juillet 2002 il ya 20 ans le défilé
militaire est en cours et le pire vient
d'être évité la stupeur des spectateurs
ce matin près de l'arc de triomphe
depuis la foule maxime brunerie jeunes
militants d'extrême droite tire sur le
président jacques chirac
la télé capte les coups de feu tendez
l'oreille c'est très bref
le président vient de prendre place dans
le véhicule découvert qui doit le
conduire place de la concorde soudain un
bruit sec
le chef de l'état n'est pas touché le
défilé continue très vite maxime
brunerie est arrêté par plusieurs
spectateurs parmi eux sept hommes
jacques weber j'ai entendu un claque je
me retourne enfin je me retourne je
pense que la tête en arrière je vois le
gars qui visait un visage déterminé à
tirer encore une fois et c'est à ce
moment là que j'ai pris le canon est
gelée basculer vers le ciel cet attentat
raté pose une question le président
était il suffisamment protégé à l'époque
il n'existe pas encore de coups et les
spectateurs question prouteau est le
fondateur du gspr la garde rapprochée du
chef de l'état et selon lui il y a eu
des manquements un dispositif de
sécurité par essence est quelque chose
qui est faillible c'est pas à 100% ça
n'existe pas la sécurisation pour ça on
peut faire qu'elle soit particulièrement
performant là mon avis il ya des trous
et ça c'est pas à moi de poser le
problème je pense que le débriefing sur
how orageux un an plus tard le 14
juillet 2003 nouveau défilé cette fois
la leçon a été comprise et la sécurité
renforcée le public est plus éloigné du
des ti les 4700 policiers sont déployés
soit 1000 de plus qu'en 2002 mais ce
n'est pas tout ce public sera dans des
enceintes barrières à l'entrée desquels
ils auront été soumis à un certain
nombre de contrôles détecteurs de métaux
fouilles des sacs et éventuellement par
une passion les spectateurs sont
fouillés pour le défilé c'est une
première
je pense qu'avec ce qui s'est passé
l'année dernière
pour fériés aussi quand même enfin là
dedans je peux je peux pas mettre de
fusil j'ai essayé aujourd'hui le défilé
militaire est toujours sous très haute
surveillance les voitures sont
interdites dans la zone des champs
elysées et plusieurs stations de métro
sont fermées en 2017 pour la première
fois un drone militaire a même été
mobilisés pour assurer la sécurité du
défilé
[Musique]